the debates are over
that is to say Donald Trump's debates
against Hillary Clinton are over but
Donald Trump's debates against America
and democracy may only be beginning last
night he made a statement in front of
tens of millions of Americans that
should by itself and not just his
candidacy for but also his eligibility
to be President
throughout the media last night on this
morning it has been treated as something
new and shocking it is neither it is
just that this time it was not hidden by
the breathing barrage of stupidity and
arrogance and delusion this man is in
short Trump did not get away with it
this time
moderator your running mate governor
pence pledged on Sunday that he and you
his words will absolutely accept the
result of this election today your
daughter Ivanka said the same thing I
want to ask you here on the stage
tonight do you make the same commitment
that you will absolutely sir that you
will absolutely accept the result of
this election Trump I will look at it at
the time I'm not looking at anything now
I'll look at it at the time at that
exact moment he lost the election
if Trump still had a chance it vanished
right then and then if he had a chance
to regain perhaps some dignity to not
pull down his supporters and his party
with him he blew that as well
moderator there is a tradition in this
country in fact one of the prides of
this country is the peaceful transition
of power and that no matter how hard
fought a campaign is that at the end of
the campaign the loser concedes to the
winner not saying that you're
necessarily going to be the loser or the
winner but that the loser concedes to
the winner and that the country comes
together in part for the good of the
country are you saying you're not
prepared now to commit to that principle
Trump what I'm saying is that I will
tell you at the time I'll keep you in
suspense okay burn in hell
17 days ago in this space I quoted
Donald Trump's whiny interview from the
New York Times on September 30th having
had it only drawn out of him with
rhetorical pliers in the first debate
that he would support Hillary Clinton if
she were alive
he then reneged on that promise 20 days
ago saying quote we're going to have to
see we're going to see what happens
we're going to have to see it was as I
observed then the first time in American
history through dozens of venomous
painful campaigns and a series of
impossibly close elections the first and
only time that a candidate of a major
party had violated the fundamental
precept of our democracy it shakes every
one of our freedoms it mocks every dead
American soldier it spits at every
sacrifice made under our flag it has no
comparison not to Al Gore not to Samuel
Tilden not to Andrew Jackson it foments
revolution it was and is the moral
equivalent of treason and this time it
slipped past no one not the moderator
not Fox News not even breitbart.com no
one it was not a flash of anger from a
man who gets angry once an hour it was
not another slab of red meat throne to
his crazed supporters it was not another
outrageous statement to throw up against
the wall in this cheap reality game show
version of a presidential campaign he
meant it he means it he meant it on
September 30th to the New York Times and
he meant it last night when Chris
Wallace asked him about it and he meant
it again last night when Chris Wallace
gave him a chance to back away from it
Donald Trump is not invested in
democracy Donald Trump is not invested
in our Constitution Donald Trump is not
invested in America Donald Trump is not
invested in preventing people from being
killed on the streets after an election
like this were a third-world police
state I will look at it at the time I'm
not looking at anything now I'll look at
it at the time what I'm saying is that I
will tell you at the time I'll keep you
in suspense okay
burn in hell last night this moved
beyond Trump and his ego and his mental
illness and his inability to understand
that the country is full of people the
other people on this planet as well all
of them are not just props in some sort
of television series starring Donald
Trump this is now about the
can party and its responsibilities to
the democracy and its responsibilities
to the Constitution and its
responsibilities to America Reince
Priebus Mitch McConnell Paul Ryan John
Cornyn Kevin McCarthy marco rubio george
w bush george HW bush this man will not
promise that he will honor the sanctity
the inviolability of our election your
election your candidate your party right
now this moment uncorrect admire you
this man is advocating violence or
passive resistance to a presidential
election and if you do not act against
him you will be blamed for him and you
will fall with him this is bigger than
who is the next president or who is the
next RNC chair or who is the next
Speaker of the House this is our
democracy imperiled from within by a man
you have permitted to speak for you and
to speak for millions of loyal Americans
who suddenly realize that the nominee of
their party is willing to subvert the
election and to subvert the democracy
itself compel him to withdraw now
litigate against him find enough doctors
and have him declared psychiatrically
incompetent at minimum cut off his
funding completely and denounce him in
the strongest possible terms because
this nightmare this fascist this Trump
is now your responsibility and after
what he said on September 30th and after
what he said last night and after what
he repeated last night it is no longer
enough for him to simply lose this
election he must now not be given the
opportunity to keep us in suspense
he must now not be given the option to
look at it at the time the defense and
viability and future of this democracy
now depends on this man being removed by
any legal means from being able to
further act against this democracy
whether the Republican ticket or the
Democratic ticket gets the most votes on
election night and in the electoral
college is in this context incidental
the issue now is a man who
on three occasions assailed the most
precious component of our 240 years of
freedom and by so doing encouraged
others to also subvert it and ignore it
and whether you the Republican Party
will permit him in the next 19 days to
do it a fourth time or a fifth time or a
hundredth time or a thousandth time will
you or will you act on behalf of the
United States of America give us your
answer